in 1552 a rather peculiar manuscript
surfaced in the city of Augsburg one
that was full of strange but also rather
lavish and outlandish illustrations
these images depicted all sorts of
strange phenomena from shooting stars
and fatal floods to swarms of locusts
and terrifying monsters stories of
ancient folklore stories of the Old
Testament and the Book of Revelation
visions that were spectacular Eerie
Prophecies of unavoidable dread and
disaster and of course no book of
medieval Horrors is complete without
mention of the apocalypse and the end of
days that is coming for us all but it's
not all doom and gloom some of these
illustrations are certainly confusing
but the vast majority are unique and
creative in a creepy nightmare fuel but
still kind of interesting way so join me
today as we take a look at the book of
Miracles and Embark and what I can only
imagine is the equivalent to a
Renaissance Acid
Trip the manuscript was originally known
as the orberg book of miraculous signs
this was shortened to the book of
miracles in 2013 when it was translated
and published in English French and
German we don't know for certain who
created this manuscript but we do know
that they were an avid collector of some
of the strangest art the Middle Ages had
to offer these illustrations give us an
insight into 16th century Europe and its
growing obsession with extraordinary
signs sent by God now these are by no
means new and unique ideas all
throughout civilization we've always had
traditions of Omens and prophecy we can
go as far back as classical Antiquity
with the ancient Greeks and Romans the
Bible itself is full of Prophecy in
ancient Greece Homer discussed the
behavior of birds and changes in the the
weather rainbows and thunder for example
were signs from the gods that could be
interpreted as both negative and
positive the Romans called this
prodigium or Prodigy in English it
differs from the Greeks as to them it
was mostly negative foretelling some
kind of Calamity or catastrophic event
the book of prodigies was created in the
4th Century ad by Julius obse sequins
this covered events from the years 249
BC all the way up to 11 BC the book of
prodigies resurfaced during the Middle
Ages in Europe or what is referred to as
the Renaissance period it's also
important to note that this was at a
time when the church had been divided
into Roman Catholics and Protestants
this in itself is known as the
Reformation period this split resulted
in propaganda from both sides each
trying to use signs from God to bolster
their views and beliefs due to the
rising interest in the idea of Prophecy
and signs from God the republishing of
this work was a huge success another
major influence came from the imagery of
Prophecy found in the Bible the olsburg
book of Miracles attempted to mimic the
structure of the Bible beginning with
the Old Testament and ending with
Revelation it wasn't until the 15th and
16th centuries that we began to see
Works similar to The Book of prodigies
resurface in parts of Europe Sebastian
brentt was known for his articles in the
broad sheets the broad sheets being the
earliest forms of newspapers he wrote
about monsters astronomical events and
various other Wonders that could not be
explained this was followed by the
publishing of multiple manuscripts which
attempted to compile these miraculous
signs together across Central Europe
there was a growing concern for these
types of signs mostly in part due to the
interests in astr rological prophecy
authors began to try and predict world
affairs by using the positioning of
celestial bodies and the citings of
comets with the rise of Illustrated
broad sheets pamphlets and the early
framework of news media these images
were able to circulate and spread
further and faster than before in July
1490 George glocken published a broad
sheet that depicted what was described
as a Celestial phenomenon near
Constantinople
the illustration depicts an armored
Knight with three heads a crowned Sun
the moon and a star the Knight is
holding a maiden before him which has
wings instead of arms the lower regions
of a lion and a serpentine tail the
woman is standing on two Shields bearing
the letter W it has been suggested that
this vision is perhaps related to the
northern lights and a meteorological
phenomenon however this is merely an
examp example of some of the Oddities
similar to those that appear in the book
of Miracles it also follows the same
format as the majority of broad sheets
there is an illustration followed by a
brief description of the event a vague
attempt to interpret and explain the
meaning which ultimately circles back to
uncertainty and the idea that only God
can truly understand lastly the faithful
are reminded that they can be spared if
they repent that is a very simplified
summary of what we see in the book of
Miracles but given that context I
believe we are more than ready to delve
into the book
itself so what exactly was the purpose
of this book why have all these images
drawn and collected in the first place
the book of Miracles contains accounts
and descriptions of miraculous signs
that have appeared throughout history it
starts with accounts from the Old
Testament and continues through
Antiquity and the Middle Ages it
eventually ends with signs from heaven
that were described in the Book of
Revelation the book's Creator attempted
to compile a record of all of the signs
from God going as far back as the start
of civilization all the way until the
end it's essentially one big Omen made
up of many smaller signs that all lead
to one thing the apocalypse a rapidly
growing concern at the time this work
was published the first few stories from
the Old Testament are familiar ones the
book begins with the great flood we see
several images of Noah's Ark along with
humans and animals fighting to survive
following the flood came the double
rainbow symbolic of God's covenant with
Humanity we also see the signs of the
zodiac symbolic of the 12 months of the
year this momentary piece is followed by
the destruction of Sodom and Gomorrah
cities which Humanity saw burnt To The
Ground by God because of their sins and
wickedness many of the illustrations
from the Old Testament are Visions from
prophets we see Elijah being taken up to
heaven in a chariot in Daniel's Vision
which is symbolic of the end times four
beasts emerge from the sea that
represent the four kingdoms that will be
vanquished and replaced by the rule of
God ezekiel's Vision concludes the Old
Testament section in the book of
Miracles now onto the Antiquity portion
of the book which is where things start
to get very weird the Golden Ball or the
Roman Fireball of 76 BC depicts a golden
ball that was seen in the sky over a
Roman Kingdom the ball came down to
earth landed and rolled around before
eventually flying back up in the air to
block the rising son this was Then
followed by a great Roman Civil War
Scholars at the time disagreed with
their description of the event some
believed it must have been a shooting
star others described it as balls of
fire as well as night Suns and torches
an article written by NASA over 30 years
ago tried to explain this phenomena but
could never confirm what exactly the
unidentified flying object was most were
in agreement that it must have been a
meteoric fireball although they couldn't
offer an explanation for it landing and
flying back up in the sky there are rare
occasions of meteorites falling and
burning so bright that they resemble a
glowing orb ill illustrations that
involve the sun were quite common in the
book of Miracles and we can take a look
at a few more of these the golden circle
around the Sun 1 BC depicts a scene in
Rome where on the day of the Nativity a
Golden Circle appeared around the Sun
for the entire day we also see the
Temple of Peace and the statue of
Romulus collapsing a potential sign of
turbulent times ahead in
938 ad there was a spree of of sudden
deaths in the city of Venice several
days before the deaths occurred those in
Venice claimed that the sun was sweating
blood a bad Omen that could only result
in Bloodshed if you're someone who
prefers their son with a creepy face
then the book of Miracles also has you
covered for example we have the five
sons of lipsig where I quote on the 21st
of March of this 51st year five Sons
were seen in liy
by many trustworthy persons now outside
of the Sun the moon the stars comets and
adverse weather they're all things we'd
understand or expect to see in the sky
some of them may have been embellished
and re-imagined but there is also a
plethora visions and things that just do
not belong in the sky illustrations
whose meanings are very hard to
comprehend or explain 1553 saw a vision
over the city of Strasburg a bloody
swordsman defending a fiery Citadel from
an opposing Army on Horseback
1536 in the skies of Medina Spain we see
another battle in the sky but one of a
far less Epic Proportion the celestial
Battle of three children is certainly
one of the stranger and more comical
pieces in the book personally I find the
children's appearance to be slightly
disturbing on the 17th of May 1552 the
city of dorre experienced a storm so
severe that people were convinced the
day of judgment was upon them hail
Stones weighing several pounds fell from
the sky for half an hour and the locals
recalled a frightening stench from these
Stones remaining in the Netherlands the
town of meelan suffered from what is
described as a special sign from God in
August of
1546 fire fell from the sky onto a
building that was housing four 400 tons
of gunpowder this caused an explosion so
big that half of the city was burnt down
four years prior the city of Augsburg
also experienced a fire in the sky but
luckily for them it remained in the sky
the fire was described as a Celestial
fire that burned like a great brazer in
the clouds at midnight this Burning
torch that appears as the front cover of
the book of Miracles tells of an event
in the year
1009 ad the sun is described as going
dark what we can assume was an eclipse
the moon turned a blood red and a great
earthquake Was Then followed by a huge
burning torch falling from the sky this
was Then followed by A Great Famine
across Germany and Italy one where more
people died than survived what's
interesting about this is that blood
moons and eclipses are seen multiple
times throughout the Book of Miracles
and are also followed by by earthquakes
this idea in itself isn't as outlandish
as some of the other images we know that
during a total lunar eclipse the moon
can appear with an orange or reddish
tint research between the correlation of
earthquakes and the lunar eclipse is
still ongoing but if we imagine we were
someone living thousands of years ago
and all of a sudden the Sun Goes dark
and the moon turns red it's not really
that unreasonable to panic and assume
the world is ending
earlier I did mention that the book
contains illustrations of monsters from
various myths and folklore in 1533
dragons wearing crowns were seen flying
through the sky over Bohemia and in the
same year we see dragons flying through
the sky this time in the evening the
wondrous hen and wondrous fish depict
some rather strange Monsters the left
shows a four-legged hen that died
shortly after it was born and on the
right right we have what appears to be a
human fish hybrid that was caught in the
Danish sea and taken back to Copenhagen
in 1534 fisherman in Venice captured a
miraculous creature which was taken back
to the city and painted judging by the
illustration it is very much reminiscent
of a Hydra the monster of salburg
depicts a creature that was caught by a
Bishop's Huntsman in a forest near sburg
this hairy four-legged creature has
sharp claws gray fur and most
disturbingly the face and beard of a man
now if I had to guess given its location
in Austria I'd assume it was some kind
of early iteration of Krampus however
much more sensible individuals have
speculated this could have been a
painting of a sloth given their natural
habitats are the rainforests of Central
and South
America the Tyber monster depicts a
creature creature that was found in the
Tyber river near Rome days after a flood
this Chimera like creature has the Torso
of a human the head of a donkey a face
on its backside and a Serpent's tail
whoever Drew this image certainly took
inspiration from Lucas cranic the Elder
one of if not the most famous artists to
emerge from the Renaissance period his
sketch is almost identical however Lucas
cranic certainly doesn't mention a
monster that appears before or after a
flood krennic's work appeared in a broad
sheet titled the papal ass a satirical
take on the pope and his monks it was
then labeled as Protestant propaganda
and during the Reformation period this
image was used as it depicted the pope
as some kind of demonic goat on October
in the year of 1527 a comet was spotted
in Westridge Germany however this was no
ordinary Comet it was extremely long its
color was described as yellowish red
similar to diluted blood at the front
which was presumed to be the head there
was an arm holding a sword poised ready
to strike at the tip of the sword there
were three stars and from those Stars a
stream longer than the comet itself this
same scene is depicted again on the very
next page only with some subtle
differences this time there were dozens
of tiny swords and long streaks thought
to be javelins we also saw some creepy
faces bearded men in the shape of gray
clouds this was described as so
terrifying that anyone who saw it
immediately died so what do these two
paintings mean well as for each
individual element I'm afraid I have no
idea comets are a recurring theme in the
book of Miracles as well as Renaissance
Art in general almost every civilization
as far far back as we can go have
depicted comets or meteors in some form
today we are more than aware of what
comets are however hundreds and
thousands of years ago seeing a fiery
ball shoot across the sky understandably
would have been a terrifying experience
this fear of the unknown is why they
normally represent some kind of Doomsday
or cataclysmic event it's why they are
almost always seen as a bad omen of
course throughout the book of Miracles
we see the standard doomsday scenes with
great floods earthquakes swarms of
locusts and all sorts of natural
disasters the book of Miracles concludes
its visions of the Apocalypse with
accounts from The Book of Revelation the
arrival of the Four Horsemen is followed
by the openings of seals 5 and six seven
trumpets were given to the angels when
the first Angel blew his trumpet it was
followed by hail of blood and Fire a
third of the Earth was scorched in flame
when the third Angel blew his trumpet a
star known as wormwood fell from the sky
and onto a third of the Earth's Rivers
the waters became bitter and many who
drank from them died when the fourth
Angel blew his trumpet a third of the
Sun the moon and the stars were struck a
third of light they provided was gone
and the world darkened when the fifth
angel blew his trumpet the Earth was
infested Ed with a plague of locust when
Angel Number Six blew his trumpet Four
Angels were released whose job it was to
kill a third of mankind from the sea
emerged a seven-headed monster
accompanied by the Antichrist amongst
those praying and worshiping its arrival
in this image we see the pope and his
Bishops along with others dressed in
Catholic Garb considering the
inspiration from the Tyber monster for
many this scene cements the idea that
the person behind the creation of this
book must have been Protestant the book
ends with one final piece titled the
fall of Babylon Babylon being a city
symbolic of sin demons and evil spirits
an angel calls out announcing to all
those that Babylon has
fallen overall the book of Miracles
provides us an interesting and rather
strange look at the attitudes and fears
that many had hundreds of years ago the
recurring theme in the book of Miracles
is the fear of the unknown today we have
the luxury of Simply knowing much more
about the world we live in with
scientific advancements we now know when
an eclipse is going to happen witnessing
a shooting star or meteor shower is an
event that people look forward to as
terrifying and destructive as natural
disasters can be we know what causes
them remove all of this knowledge and
were left with events that can't be
explained the book of Miracles and other
Christian art of the time took these
fears and rationalize them in a way that
civilizations had been doing for
thousands of years they became signs
from God they told stories of the
impending judgment and doom that
Humanity would have to face one could
certainly make the argument that being
told these events were signs of the end
of the world may have been slightly more
frightening than simp L not knowing
although as someone who does enjoy some
Cosmic horror fear of the unknown can
also be just as
[Music]
terrifying